well good evening I would like to
welcome everybody ad tonight we have a
packed house and it's brilliant to see
my name is Michael link I'm the
operations manager here at politics and
burrows and this is actually the third
time that I have encountered Richard
Dawkins who if you don't know will be
speaking tonight if he thought it was
somebody else then you should give up
your seat now because there are people
waiting the first time was when I was in
college studying philosophy which is a
bad choice unless you wanted up here
which then would be good choice when I
was studying his book The Blind
watchmaker the last time as when we were
speaking before the event I realized
when when we hosted an event for the
devil's chaplain was actually when
President Bush had traveled to England
and the worst mass protests there and
now that we're having an event for his
newest book the ancestors tale I
realized that Tony Blair's here so I've
come to think of Richard Dawkins is kind
of an ambassador of international
relations when he puts out a new book
it's sort of it bodes well at least for
the two members of the Coalition of the
Willing
and don't forget Poland so I also think
that this is this is an amazing time
because I've been reading recently about
a number of school districts across the
country who have since yeah thank you
have since began to pave the way for
intelligent design or creationism to be
taught in public schools and if any of
you have ever read anything written by
Richard Dawkins you know that he is not
necessarily the biggest proponent of
such a scientific view and it was
actually during this latest round as I
was finishing his latest book which is
without a doubt brilliant it's it's
brilliant from the point of view it's
brilliantly written and I it's amazing
that it wasn't quite enough to to write
a book about our ancestors to write a
book about evolutionary biology but I
guess just to make it a challenge
Richard wrote it in sort of the style of
The Canterbury Tales so without further
ado it is my distinct pleasure to
welcome tonight as many of you know who
were here for the devil's chaplain what
is an absolutely brilliant presentation
I now turn the mics over to Richard and
[Applause]
Tony Blair may be willing but he's alone
in our country the ancestors tale as
you've heard is modelled vaguely after
the Canterbury Tales the main thing that
distinguishes it from any other history
is that it goes backwards and the first
chapter the conceit of hindsight
explains the rationale for going
backwards it is a conceit of hindsight
to see evolution as aimed towards some
particular end points such as ourselves
a historically my
it's Swift understandably proud of
flight as self-evidently the premiere
accomplishment of life might regard
swift kind those spectacular flying
machines were there swept-back wings who
stay aloft for a year at a time and even
copulate in free flight as the Acme of
evolutionary progress to build on a
fancy of Steven Pinker
if elephants could write history they
might portray tape ears elephant shrews
elephant seals and proboscis monkeys has
tentative beginners along the main trunk
road of evolution taking the first
fumbling steps but each for some reason
never quite making it so near yet so far
elephant astronomers might wonder
whether on some other world there exists
alien life-forms that have crossed the
nasal Rubicon and taken the final leap
to full prabhasa two'd we are neither
Swift's nor elephants we are people as
we wander in imagination through some
long dead geological epoch it's humanly
natural to reserve a special warmth and
curiosity for whichever otherwise
ordinary species in that ancient
landscape is our ancestor it's an
intriguing ly unfamiliar thought that
there's always one such species it's
hard to deny our human temptation to see
this one species is on the main line of
evolution the others a supporting cast
walk-on parts sidelined cameos without
succumbing to that error there is one
way to indulge a legitimate human
centrism while respecting historical
propriety that way is to do our history
backwards and it is the way of this book
the ancestors tale is cast in the form
of an epic pilgrimage from the present
to the past all roads lead to the origin
of life but because we are human the
path we shall follow will be a human
pilgrimage to discover human ancestors
as we go we shall greet other pilgrims
who join us at a series of rendezvous
points
as we encounter the common ancestor we
share with each of them the first fellow
pilgrims we greet some five million
years ago deep in Africa where Stanley
memorably shook hands with Livingstone
other chimpanzees a million years
further into the past the gorillas join
us then the orangutans next the Gibbons
then monkeys and so on until we finally
greet the bacteria after which all the
pilgrims marched together in one single
backward quest for the origin of life
itself life's Canterbury following
Chaucer's lead my pilgrims which are all
the different species of living creature
have the opportunity to tell tales along
the way it is these tales that form the
main substance of the book incidentally
I decided it would be twe to let them
tell their tales in the first-person
singular and as with Chaucer's tales
they're not necessarily about the tiller
but they carry a message about life or
evolution in general surprisingly there
are only 39 of these rendevouz as we
journey back the bacteria being
rendezvous 39 and in these readings
we'll just jump through just a few of
these rendevouz and a few of the tales
we go first to rendezvous - which is
about seven million years into the past
where the gorilla pilgrims join us the
gorillas tale the rise of Darwinism in
the 19th century polarized attitudes
towards the Apes opponents who might
have stomached evolution itself balked
with visceral horror at cousinship with
what they perceived as low and revolting
brutes and desperately tried to inflate
our differences from them this was
nowhere more true than with gorillas
apes were animals we were set apart
worse where other animals such as cats
or deer could be seen as beautiful in
their own way gorillas and other Apes
precisely because of their similarity to
our
selves seemed like caricatures
distortions grotesques Darwin never
missed an opportunity to put the other
view sometimes in little asides such as
his charming observation in the descent
of man that monkeys smoked tobacco with
pleasure nowadays scientists not only
think we resemble Apes we include
ourselves within the Apes specifically
the African Apes we emphasize by
contrast the distinctness of apes
including humans from monkeys to call a
gorilla or a chimpanzee a monkey is a
solecism it has not always been so in
former times apes were frequently lumped
with monkeys and some of the early
descriptions confused Apes with baboons
or with Barbary macaques which indeed
are still known as Barbary Apes more
surprisingly long before people thought
in terms of evolution at all and before
apes were clearly distinguished from
each other or from monkeys great apes
were often confused with humans
agreeable as it would be to approve this
apparent presence of evolution it
unfortunately may owe more to racism
early white explorers in Africa snore
chimpanzees and gorillas as close kin
only two black humans not to themselves
interestingly tribes in both South East
Asia and Africa have traditional legends
suggesting a reversal of evolution as
conventionally seen their local great
apes are regarded as humans who fell
from grace or rangu tan means man of the
woods in Malay a picture of an orangutan
by the Dutch dr. Pontius in 1658 is in
th Huxley's words nothing but a very
hairy woman of rather comely aspect and
with proportions and feet holy human
hairy she is except oddly in one of the
few places where a real woman is her
pubic region is conspicuously naked also
very human are the pictures made a
century later by Linnaeus his pupil
hoppiest in 1763 one of his creatures
has a tail but is otherwise wholly human
bipedal and carry
a walking stick Pliny the Elder says
that the tale species have even been
known to play at checkers one might have
thought that such a mythology would have
prepared our civilization for the idea
of evolution when it arrived in the 19th
century and might even have accelerated
its discovery apparently not
instead the picture is one of confusion
between Apes monkeys and humans this
makes it hard to date the scientific
discovery of each species of great ape
and is often unclear which one is being
discovered the exception is the gorilla
which became known to science the most
recently in 1847 an American missionary
dr. thomas savage saw in the house of
another missionary on the gaboon River a
skull represented by the natives to be a
monkey like animal remarkable for its
size ferocity and habits the unjust
reputation for ferocity was later to be
hyperbolized in the story of King Kong
judging from its location savages
species must have been the Western
gorilla gorilla gorilla the mountain
gorilla was discovered he shot it by the
german robert von Behring er as late as
1902 as we shall see it is now regarded
as a subspecies of the eastern gorilla
and the whole eastern species now
unfairly one might think bears his name
gorilla
baron GI the pygmies originally
mentioned by homer and Herodotus as a
legendary race of very small humans were
later assumed by 17th and 18th century
explorers to be none other than the
chimpanzees then being discovered in
Africa Tyson 1699 shows a drawing of a
pygmy witch's Huxley says is plainly a
young chimpanzee although it too is
depicted walking upright and carrying a
walking stick now of course we use the
word pygmy for small humans again this
leads us back to the racism which until
relatively late in the 20th century was
endemic in our culture early explorers
often assigned the native peoples of the
forest
her closer affinity with chimpanzees
gorillas or orangs than with the
explorers themselves in the 19th century
after Darwin evolutionists often
regarded African peoples as intermediate
between Apes and Europeans on the upward
path to white supremacy this is not only
factually wrong it violates a
fundamental principle of evolution two
cousins are always exactly equally
related to any art group because they
are connected to that out group via a
shared ancestor for reasons given in the
bonobos tale all humans are exactly
equally close cousins to all gorillas
racism and speciesism and our perennial
confusion over how inclusively we wish
to cast our moral and ethical net are
brought into sharp and sometimes
uncomfortable focus in the history of
our attitudes to our fellow humans and
our attitudes to apes our fellow Apes
moving back now from rendezvous to to
rendezvous 10 back to 75 million years
ago where we're joined by the rodents
rendezvous 10 rodents rodents are one of
the great success stories of mammal tum'
more than 40% of all mammal species are
rodents and there are said to be more
individual rodents in the world than all
other mammals combined rats and mice
have been the hidden beneficiaries of
our own agricultural revolution and
they've traveled with us across the seas
to every land in the world they
devastate our granaries and our health
rats and their cargo of fleas were
responsible for the Great Plague and
arguably the Black Death they've spread
typhus and have been blamed for more
human deaths in the second millennium
than all wars and revolutions put
together when even the Four Horsemen of
the Apocalypse are laid low it will be
rats that scavenge their remains
rats that will swarm over the ruins of
civilization rodents are gnawing
machines they have a pair of very
prominent incisor teeth at the front but
actually growing to replace massive wear
and tear rodents kannur their way
through almost anything
most of mouse-sized but they range up
through marmots beavers booties and
maras to the Sheep sized capybaras of
the South American waterways capybaras
are prized for meat not just because of
their large size but because bizarrely
the Roman Catholic Church traditionally
deemed them honorary fish for Friday's
presumably because they live in water
large as they are modern capybaras are
dwarfed by various giant South American
rodents that went extinct only quite
recently but giant capybara proto Hydra
Karras was the size of a donkey telly
Comus was an even larger rodent the size
of a small rhinoceros which like the
giant capybara went extinct at the time
of the great American interchange when
the Isthmus of Panama ended South
America's islands status a world without
rodents would be a very different world
it is less likely to come to pass than a
world dominated by rodents and free of
people if nuclear war destroys humanity
and most of the rest of life a good bet
for survival in the short term and for
evolutionary ancestry in the long term
is rats I have a post Armageddon vision
we and all other large animals are gone
rodents emerge as the ultimate post
humans scavengers they nor their way
through New York London and Tokyo
digesting spilled Ladas ghosts
supermarkets and human corpses and
turning them into new generations of
rats and mice who's racing populations
explode out of the cities and into the
countryside when all the relics of human
profligacy are eaten populations crash
again and the rodents turn on each other
and on the cockroaches scavenging with
them in a period of intense competition
short generations perhaps with
radioactively enhanced mutation rates
boost rapid evolution with human ships
and planes gone Islands become Islands
again
with local populations isolated save for
occasional lucky rafting 'he's
ideal conditions for evolutionary
divergence within 5 million years a
whole range of new species replaced the
ones we know herds of giant grazing
rat's arse talked by saber-tooth
predatory rats given enough time will a
species of intelligent cultivated rats
emerge will rodent historians and
scientists eventually organize careful
archeological gnaws through the strata
of our long compacted cities and
reconstruct the peculiar and temporally
tragic circumstances that gave rat kind
its big break back one more rendezvous
to rendezvous 11 we're joined about 85
million years ago by the Laurasia Thea's
which is a very large group of animals
not until recently realized to be a
group at all they include the carnivores
the horses the cattle the bats shrews
many other creatures and we're now going
to read the hippos tail when I was a
schoolboy studying Greek I learned that
hippos meant horse and Potamus River
hippopotamuses were River horses later
when I gave up Greek and read zoology I
was not too disconcerted to learn that
hippopotamuses weren't close to horses
after all instead they were classified
firmly with pigs in the middle of the
even-toed ungulates or artiodactyls
I have now learned something so shocking
that I'm still reluctant to believe it
but it looks as though I'm going to have
two hippos closest living relatives are
whales the even-toed ungulates include
whales whales needless to say don't have
hooves at all whether our door even toad
indeed they don't have toes whales are
wonders of the world they include the
largest organisms that have ever moved
they swim
with up-and-down movements of the spine
derived from the mammalian gallop as
opposed to the side-to-side wave motion
of the spine of a swimming fish or a
running lizard presumably are swimming
ichthyosaur which in other respects
looked rather like a dolphin except for
the tell-tale vertical tail where the
Dolphins is horizontal for galloping
through the sea the front limbs are used
for steering and stabilizing there are
no externally visible hind limbs at all
but some whales have small vestigial
pelvic and leg bones buried deep in
their bodies it would not be too hard to
believe that whales are closer cousins
to even-toed ungulates than they are to
other mammals a bit strange perhaps but
not shocking to accept that some remote
ancestor branched to the left and went
to sea to give rise to the whales while
it branched to the right to give the
even-toed ungulates what is shocking is
that according to the molecular evidence
whales are deeply embedded within the
even-toed ungulates hippos are closer
cousins to whales than hippos are to
anything else including other even-toed
ungulates such as pigs something
happened in the history of the whales
but made them flip into evolutionary
overdrive their closest cousins the
hippos remained relatively static as
normal respectable artiodactyls the
whales evolved so much faster than all
the rest of the artiodactyls that their
origin within that group was obscured
until molecular taxonomy came along and
uncovered it so what is special about
the history of the whales when you write
it down like that the solution leaps off
the page leaving the land and becoming
wholly aquatic was a bit like going into
outer space when we go into space we are
weightless a whale floats unlike a seal
or a turtle which still comes on land to
breed a whale never stops floating it
never has to contend with gravity a
hippo spends time in the water but it
still needs stout tree trunk like legs
and strong leg muscles for the land a
whale doesn't need legs
all and it doesn't have any think of a
whale as what a hippo would like to be
if only it could be freed from the
tyranny of gravity and of course there
are so many other odd things about
living the whole time in the sea that it
comes to seem far less surprising that
whale evolution should have spurted as
it did leaving hippos behind stranded on
land and stranded in the middle of the
artiodactyls much the same thing
happened in the other direction 300
million years earlier when our fish
ancestors emerge from the water onto the
land
if whales are glorified hippos we are
all glorified lungfish the emergence of
legless whales from within the middle of
the artiodactyls eating the rest of the
artiodactyls behind should not see more
surprising than the emergence of
four-legged land animals from one
particular group of fish leaving those
fish behind that at any rate is how I
rationalize the hippo whale connection
and recover my lost zoological composure
so logical composure be blowed my
attention was drawn to the following
while this book was in its final stages
of preparation in 1866 the great German
zoologist Ernst Haeckel drew up a
schematic evolutionary tree of mammals
I'd often seen the full tree reproduced
in histories of zoology but I'd never
before noticed the position of the
whales and hippos in Haeckel scheme echo
presently placed the whales close to the
artiodactyls but the real stunner is
where he put the hippos he called them
by the unflattering name of bisa and he
classified them not in the artiodactyls
but as a tiny twig on the branch leading
to the whales there is no new thing
under the Sun is there anything we're
off it may be said see this is new it
has been already of old time which was
before us Ecclesiastes 1:9 - 10
back now to rendezvous 16 where that's
about 310 million years ago where we
mammals are joined by all the reptiles
where reptiles includes birds because
birds are of course merely modified
dinosaurs the elephant birds tail from
the tales of the Arabian Nights the
image that most stirred my childish
imagination was the rock encountered by
Sinbad the sailor who at first thought
this monstrous bird was a cloud come
over the Sun I had heard a 4-time of
pilgrims and travelers how in a certain
island dwelleth a huge bird called the
rock which feedeth its young on
elephants The Legend of the rock or rock
surfaces in several stories of the
Arabian Nights it is mentioned by Marco
Polo as living in Madagascar and envoy's
from the king of Madagascar was said to
have presented the Khan of Cathay with a
rock feather Michael Drayton invoked the
monstrous Birds name to contrast it with
the proverbially tiny wren all feathered
things yet ever known to men from the
huge rock unto the little Wren what is
the origin of the rock legend and if it
is pure fantasy whence the recurrent
connection with Madagascar fossils from
Madagascar tell us that a gigantic bird
the elephant bird EP honest Maximus
lived there perhaps until as late as the
17th century although more probably
around a thousand AD the elephant bird
finally succumbed perhaps partly through
people stealing its eggs which were up
to a metre in circumference and would
have provided as much food as 200
chicken eggs the elephant bird was 3
metres tall and weighed nearly half a
ton as much as 5 ostriches
unlike the legendary rock which used its
mighty wingspan to carry Sinbad aloft as
well as elephants the real elephant bird
could not fly and its wings were small
like an ostriches
but they were cousin it will be wrong to
imagine it as a scaled-up ostrich it was
a more robust heavyset bird a kind of
feathered tank with a big head and neck
unlike the ostriches slender periscope
given how legends readily grow and
inflate a pianist is a plausible
progenitor of the rock the elephant bird
was probably vegetarian unlike the
fabulously jumbo fergus rock and unlike
earlier groups of giant carnivorous
birds such as the forest record family
of the new world they could grow to the
same height as he be honest with a
fearsomely hooked beak which as if in
justification of their nickname of
feathered tyrannosaurs looks capable of
swallowing a medium-sized lawyer whole
these monstrous cranes seem at first
sight better casting for the role of the
terrifying rock than eat the illness but
they went extinct too long ago to have
started the legend and in any case
Sinbad or his real-life Arab
counterparts never visited the Americas
the elephant bird of Madagascar is the
heaviest bird known to have lived but
it's not the longest some species of MOA
could reach a height of 3.5 meters but
only if the neck was raised as in one
early museum mounting in life it seems
they normally carried the head only a
little way above the back but the mower
cannot have generated the rock
collection for New Zealand - was well
beyond Sinbad's Ken about ten more
species existed in New Zealand and they
ranged in size from Turkey to double
sized ostrich mowers are extreme among
flightless birds in that they have no
trace of wings at all not even buried
vestiges of wing bones they thrived in
both the North and South Islands of New
Zealand until the recent invasion by the
Maori people about 1250 ad they were
easy prey no doubt for the same reason
as the dodo except for the extinct haast
seagull the largest eagle ever to have
lived they'd known no predators for tens
of millions of years and Lamar is
slaughtered them all eating the choice
of parts and discarding the rest the
lying
for the first time the wishful myth of
the noble savage living in respectful
harmony with his environment by the time
the Europeans arrived only a few
centuries after the maari's the last MOA
was gone
legends and tall stories of sightings
persists to this day but the hope is
forlorn in the words of a plaintive song
to be sung in a mournful New Zealand
accent no more no more you know die T
Aurora can't get them they vet 'm
they've gone and there ain't no MOA the
elephant-bird
tale goes on to discuss the molecular
taxonomy not just of existing large
flightless birds ratite birds like
ostriches and emus but also the elephant
bird itself because enough traces remain
to get some DNA and of mowers again
because enough DNA remains with
fascinating results and the conclusion
to the tale is about the geological
theory of plate tectonics the drifting
of the continents that's typical of the
way I'm using the tails to give more
general lessons about evolution we now
move back to rendezvous 26 out of the 39
altogether and this is where most of the
invertebrate pilgrims greet us at 590
million years ago the barnacles tail
when I was at boarding school it was
occasionally necessary to apologize to
the house master for being late for
dinner
sorry I'm late Sir orchestra practice or
whatever the excuse might be on those
occasions when there really was no good
excuse and we had something to hide we
formed the habit of saying sorry I'm
late Sir barnacles he always nodded
he always nodded kindly and I don't know
whether he ever wondered what this
mysterious out-of-school activity might
be it is possible that we were inspired
by the example of Darwin who devoted
years of his life to barnacles
so single-mindedly that his children
were moved to ask in innocent puzzlement
after being shown round the house of
some friends well your Papa do his
barnacles I'm not sure that we knew the
Darwin's story then and I suspect that
we invented the excuse because there is
something about barnacles that seems too
implausible to be a bluff barnacles are
not what they seem that applies to other
animals too and it's the theme of the
barnacles tale contrary to all
appearances barnacles are crustaceans
the ordinary ACORN barnacles which
encrust the rocks like miniature limpets
helping your shoes not to slip if you're
wearing them and hurting your feet if
you're not a completely unlike limpets
internally inside the shell they are
distorted shrimps lying on their backs
kicking their legs in the air their feet
bare feathery combs or baskets with
which they filter particles of food out
of the water these barnacles do the same
thing but instead of sheltering under a
conical shell like an acorn barnacle
they sit on the end of a stout stalk
they get their name from yet another
misunderstanding of the true nature of
barnacles they're wet filtering feathers
give them the appearance of a baby bird
in its egg in the days when people
believed in spontaneous generation a
folk belief grew that goose barnacles
hatched into geese specifically Brant
Alou copsis the barnacle goose most
deceptive of all indeed probably holding
the record for animals not looking
remotely like the thing that zoologists
know them to be of a parasitic barnacle
such as Sacculina Sacculina
is not what it seems with a vengeance so
ologists would never have realized that
it is in fact a bark
but for its larvae the adult is a soft
sack that clings to the underside of a
crab and sends long branching plant like
roots inside to absorb nourishment from
the crabs tissues the parasite not only
doesn't look like a barnacle it doesn't
look like a crustacean of any kind it
has completely lost all trace of the
armor plating and all trace of the
bodily segmentation that nearly all
other arthropods have it might as well
be a parasitic plant or fungus yet in
terms of its evolutionary relationships
it is a crustacean and not just a
crustacean but specifically a barnacle
by the way sac Elena's branching root
system is not indiscriminate in its
invasion of the crabs tissues it heads
first for the crabs reproductive organs
which has the effect of castrating the
crab is this just an accidental
byproduct probably not castration not
only sterilizes the crab like a fat
bullock the castrated crab instead of
concentrating on becoming a lean mean
reproducing machine diverts resources
towards getting larger more food for the
parasite when our going to leap straight
past Canterbury which is the origin of
life to the final chapter of the book
which is called the hosts return the
genial host having guided Chaucer and
the other pilgrims from London to
Canterbury and stood impresario 2 their
tales turned around and led them
straight back to London if I having made
the four billion year pilgrimage to the
dawn of life now return to the present
it must be alone for to presume upon
evolutions following the same forward
course twice would be to deny the
rationale of our backward journey
evolution was never aimed at a
particular end point and yet if to
borrow a thought experiment of the
American biologist Stewart Kaufman
evolution could be rerun again and again
maybe on an imaginary sample of
earth-like
planets how similar would the results be
like any theology sty can search my
mental database of life on this planet
and come up with an estimated answer to
questions of the form how many times has
X evolved independently the eye has
evolved more than 40 times to nine
different designs echolocation the trick
of emitting sound pulses and navigating
by accurate timing of the echoes has
evolved at least four times in bats
toothed whales oil birds and cave
swiftlets not as many times as the eyes
tally of 40 to 60 but still offered
enough to make a suspect that if the
conditions are right sonar will evolved
to do the counts more systematically
would make a good research project what
systems have evolved many times
independently like eyes or several times
like echolocation have some things
evolved only once or not at all
I suspect that we'd find certain
potential evolutionary pathways which
life is eager to go down other pathways
have more resistance elsewhere I
developed the analogy of a huge Museum
of all life both real and conceivable
with corridors going off in many
mathematical dimensions to represent
evolutionary change both real and
conceivable the corridor of eyes is wide
open almost beckoning other corridors
are blocked off by barriers that are
hard or even impossible to surmount
evolution repeatedly races down the easy
corridors and just occasionally and
unexpectedly leaps one of the hard
barriers but how about things that have
evolved only once or not at all the
wheel with a true freely rotating
bearing seems to have evolved only once
in bacteria before being finally
invented in human technology language 2
has apparently evolved only in us that
is to say at least 40 times less often
than the AI it is surprisingly hard to
think of good ideas that have evolved
only once
I put the challenge to my Oxford
colleague the entomologist a naturalist
George McGavin and he came up with a
nice list but still a short one compared
with a list of things that have evolved
many times bombardier beetles of the
genus Brack highness are unique in dr.
McGovern's experience in mixing
chemicals to make an explosion the
ingredients are made and held in
separate obviously glands when danger
threatens they are squirted into a
chamber near the rear end of the beetle
where they explode for cig noxious
caustic and boiling hot liquid out
through a directed nozzle at the enemy
the case is well known to creationists
who love it they think it is
self-evidently impossible to evolve by
gradual degrees because the intermediate
stages would all explode
I enjoyed demonstrating the error of
this argument during my Royal
Institution Christmas lectures for
children shown on BBC television in 1991
donning a second world war helmet and
inviting nervous members of the audience
to leave I mixed hydroquinone and
hydrogen peroxide the two ingredients of
the bombardier explosion nothing
happened it didn't even get warm
the explosion requires a catalyst I
raised the concentration of catalyst
gradually which steadily increased the
hot whoosh to a satisfactory climax in
nature the beetle provides the catalyst
and would have had no difficulty in
gradually and safely increasing the dose
over evolutionary time
next in the McGavin list is the archer
fish which may be unique in shooting a
missile to knock prey down from a
distance it comes to the surface of the
water and spits a mouthful at a perched
insect knocking it down into the water
where it eats it spitting spiders family
site oddity are a bit different again
lacking the fleetness of a wolf spider
or the net of a web spider the spitting
spider Chuck's a venomous glue some
distance towards its prey pinning it to
the ground until the
Spyder arrives and bites it to death
this is different from the archerfish
technique of knocking prey down McGavin
'he's next candidate for an evolutionary
one-off is a beauty it is the diving
bell spider our garanito Aquatica the
spider lives and hunts entirely
underwater but unlike dolphins dugongs
turtles freshwater snails and other land
animals that have returned to water I
should have said like dolphins dugongs
etc that have returned to water it needs
to breathe air unlike all those other ex
Isles our Garin dieter constructs his
own diving bell it spins it of silk silk
is the universal solution to any spider
problem attached to an underwater plant
the spider goes to the surface to
collect air which it carries in the same
way as some water bugs in a layer
trapped by body hairs but unlike the
bugs which just carry the air like a
scuba cylinder wherever they go
the spider takes it to its diving bell
where it unloads it to replenish the
supply the spider sits in the diving
bell watching for prey and it stores and
eats prey there once caught but Jorge
mud Gavin's champion example of a
one-off is the larva of an African horse
fly to bonus predictably in Africa the
pools of water in which the larvae live
and feed dry up each larvae
buries itself in the mud and Capades the
adult fly emerges from the baked mud and
flies off to feed on blood eventually to
complete the cycle by laying eggs in
pools of water when the rains return the
Buried larvae is vulnerable to a
predictable danger as mud dries out it
cracks and as a risk that a crack will
tear right across the grubs refuge it
could theoretically save itself if it
could somehow engineer away for any
crack that approaches it to be diverted
around it instead and it does indeed
achieve this in a truly wonderful and
probably unique manner before burying
itself in its own pew patient chamber at
first corkscrews it's weighed down into
the mud in a spiral
it then cooks
it's way back to the surface in an
opposite spiral finally it dives into
the mud straight down the center between
the two spirals and that is its resting
place through the bad times until water
returns now you see what this means
the lava is encased in a cylinder of mud
whose circular boundary has been
weakened in advance by the preliminary
spiral burrowing this means that we're
not crack snakes across the drying mud
if it hits the edge of the cylindrical
column instead of cutting straight
across the middle it goes instead in a
curved bypass around the edge of the
cylinder and the lava is spared it is
just like the perforations around a
stamp which stop you tearing the stamp
across dr. McGavin believes that this
ingenious trick is literally unique to
this one genus of horsefly this kind of
comparative exercise counting which
things evolve often and which seldom
might help us to predict things about
life outside this planet
which features of life are parochial and
which universal this is a question that
biologists ask less often than they
should if as returning host I reflect on
the whole pilgrimage of which I have
been a grateful part my overwhelming
reaction is one of amazement amazement
not only at the extravaganza of details
that we have seen amazement too at the
very fact that there are any such
details to be had at all on any planet
the universe could so easily have
remained lifeless and simple just
physics and chemistry just the scattered
dust of the cosmic explosion that gave
birth to time and space the fact that it
did not the fact that life evolved out
of nearly nothing some 10 billion years
after the universe evolved out of
literally nothing
he's a fact so staggering that I would
be mad to attempt words to do it justice